Know how to use a gun?
Yeah yeah, but...
(Laughs)
(Bleep)
Yeah, yeah, but...
(Prop-gun clicks)
Just shoot everyone who's not
me.
♪♪
(Thump)
(Bleep)
Yeah yeah, but...
(-Loud thump)
Hahaha...
(Bleep)
Chris Evans:
And become Marksman?
(Click)
Chris Evans:
Hahaha.
(Laughing)
Pan's Labyrinth.
♪♪
(Laughing)
(Bleep)
Arghh! Shouting, grunting.
Laughing.
I took my own feet out.
(Bleep)
Not today.
(Laughs)
-Whoooa!. I've got goosebumps.
You haven't had those since our
three-way!
(Bleep)
♪♪
-Laughing.
(Bleep)
(Sirens wail)
-Do that sound!
(Mimicking sirens)
-Laughing.
Laughing.
-(Honk-honk-honk)
(Laughing)
-That is kind of not bad!
Director:
Ready?
No.
-Laughing.
(Beep)
-She really is great.
That vitamin P you got last
night.
Laughing.
(Bleep)
♪♪
Brakes don't work!
I don't know what's happening!
(Bleep)
He went faster then me--bleep.
Laughing.
(Bleep)
Whoooa! I've got goosebumps!
You haven't has those since we
got that swinging chair!
(Bleep)
♪♪
(Thud)
(Bleep)
Ahh!
-Ohh!
Ayy-ahh!
Whoa!
(Bleep)
♪♪
(Case opens)
Laughing.
(Bleep)
If we do not deliver an
operational weapon in 48 hours,
our buyers will kill us all.
Now you find me the Taxman, or
they will not have the chance.
Cause I will kill you myself,
Hmm?
Wait, wait, wait...
Can you make sure to call your
contact and get the tickets for
Cirque du Soleil?
(Bleep)
Look, you might as well not keep
me in the dark, it's not exactly
helping us reach our goals!
Just shut up, Cole!
-Exhales.
I'm spitting all over myself!
-(Bleep)
God, you two need to get a room!
That was great, tell me that
wasn't great!
Laughing.
You going to Istanbul?
(Bleep)
You guys are doing a great job,
only six more hours.
-Laughing.
(Bleep)
What do you go for, huh?
A fairytale?
Fairytales are for children!
Laughing.
-(Bleep)
Oh God I would give up my other
eye to spend one night looking
at you.
Jonas, I'm in the middle of
something here.
(Pop!)
Ow!
I'm a dickless cyclops.
Can only hear out of one ear.
Laughing!
-♪♪
(Bleep)
♪♪
Smile for the camera.
Laughing.
-Bleep.
♪♪
(Bleep)
Which means he still has Aztec.
-Which means changes pla...
(grunts)
Bleep-uking!
Laughing.
-(Bleep)
Whoooa! I've got goosebumps!
You haven't gotten those since
your acorns dropped!
- (Bleep)
Laughing.
♪♪
(Bleep)
And you are?
Laughing.
I'm sorry.
(Bleep)
We basically got it.